من القوه الى التلاشي واعلان الافلاس كانت
هذه مسيره الشاب الحالم سام بانكمان في
عالم عملات المشفره بانكمن كان المثل
الاعلى في سوق الاصول الرقميه بعد جمعه
ثروه نواصلت لاكثر من 26 مليار دولار عبر
استغلال الفرق في سعر بتكون بين اسيا
والولايات المتحده الشمس عرف بانقاذه
لمنصتين العملات المشفره ليصبح شخصيه
بارزه وغير تقليديه لقبوها اس بي اف وشركه
اختصارها
تصل قيمتها السوقيه الى اكثر من 32 مليار
دولار لكن كل شيء تغير خلال الايام
المستثمرون يهربون رغم موعود بنك مان
بالانقاذ والسيطره ليصله في النهايه الى
ضربه الافلاس القاضيه صدم العاملون في
افدي اكسبلنهيار الجميع كان ينظر للحرم
المسمى بانك وهو الوحيد الذي نظر الامر
بالواقعيه وخرج للعلن وعلنا افلاس
امبراطوريته وبقائه في مكان قامته بجزر
البهاما بانتظار ما ستصفر عنه الايام
القادمه